bonjour pèlerine merci d'être avec nous
sur rt france cet après midi qu'est ce
que vous attendez du discours de donald
trump tout à l'heure alors que moscou
bruxelles et pékin ont par exemple
contesté hier à la légalité juridique
des nouvelles sanctions visant l'iran
est-ce que donald trump est appelé à
l'unité alors que beaucoup de pays
parlent d'unilatéralisme en ce qui
concerne les états unis on espère tu je
devais avoir une patine et riad à la
chine et la russie mais probablement ils
vont annoncer aussi tellement élevées a
annoncé des sanctions contre l'iran est
probablement un tout seuls états unis
vont faire les choses qui quoi qui sont
nécessaires et se perdent
ils vont essayer de convaincre la russie
et la chine deux des lettres d'accord
est ce que aujourd'hui c'est un enjeu
particulier pour donner à 30 en pleine
campagne présidentielle américaine on
sait déjà eu des débuts du vote anticipé
dans quatre états
joe biden qui serait selon le dernier
sondage morning consultent très en
avance qui ont su % contre 44 % sur
donald trump est ce qu'un enjeu
particulier pour lui en vue de cette
élection présidentielle américaine qui
va avoir lieu le 3 novembre le rappelle
pas donc je n'ai pas complètement
compris les questions non jure par
rapport à des réunions maintenant avec
nations unies ce héros ou d'un ordre
général est ce que cette assemblée
générale cette semaine à l'onu peut
avoir un impact sur la campagne
présidentielle
excusez moi oui j'ai compris sa as
il ya aux états unis il ya moins et
moins des gens je crois qu'ils sont très
très intéressés avec les affaires
étrangères malheureusement ils sont
tellement aux etats-unis le second sujet
maintenant c'est de le mort d'une
justice et bg et de les nominations de
remplacement cour suprême mais les
choses
le ps est très très important dans nos
30 malgré tout les politiques
domestiques et les élections qu'ils
arrivent ils n'arrêtent pas de avancer
les différents programmes et projets du
p comme les accords entre les émirats et
bas rhin bas rhin avec israël et
concevoir et celui et en plus iront ils
n'oublient jamais le problème avec iron
et selon l'administration tromper
quoique ça c'est une solution pour pour
le p pour le futur du monde et et de wii
ont posées les unes bagot mais selon
grise mais permettez-moi selon de
nombreuses capitales
c'est correct juridiquement d'un point
de vue international
donc selon ce que vous dites pour donald
trump sait faire la paix mais comment
comment faire comment faire avec les
autres capitales mondiales et les autres
diplomatie pour y voir ça sera difficile
oui ça c'est difficile mais tellement tu
en as jamais si quelque chose s'est-il
ohlins politiquement diplomatiquement
avec la chine et la russie après des
sanctions
c'est ça la question ouais ça sera très
difficile mais juste parce que quelque
chose est difficile d'en trempe
il va toujours essayer de faire il va et
c'est maintenant ça c'est pour lui et la
russie la chine essaie de discuter les
horizons nécessaire à d'arrêter les vend
du lait vendu des armes à l'iran parce
que c'est pas bon il rend et était
toujours il manage toujours l'état d
israël il toujours le plus grand ce
penseur de terrorisme dans le monde
et c'est pas bien que en continu et
avant de les armes en iran on vient
d'évoquer le dossier iranien mais il ya
également une déclaration de donald
trump avant son discours ça devrait
commencer d'ici quelques instants plus
qu'il ya il y à un français qui est à la
tribune en train de s'exprimer nathan
metheny conseiller environnemental
climat de l'onu mais juste avant son
discours donc onusien donald trump a
fait une déclaration tout à l'heure au
sujet de tik tok il n'y aura pas
d'accord pour tik tok si le groupe
chinois gardent le contrôle
c'est ce qu'il a dit donald trump parce
que ce n'est pas un peu mettre la
pression sur pékin avant cette assemblée
générale de l'onu est ce que c'est pas
un peu d'ailleurs mettre de l'huile sur
le feu quand on connaît les relations
sino américaines particulièrement tendu
en ce moment oui c'est ça c'est une bord
ça c'est une news je n'étais pas au
courant j'ai cru qu'il y avait un accord
avec oi matière oracle donc ça c'est
nouveau donc
s'il n'y a pas d'accord aujourd'hui oui
bah je sais pas quoi dire oui c'est ça
il doit c'est de trouver une solution
mais je ne peux pas fait une
commentaires et avec des déclarations
comme ça avant de monter à la tribune de
l'onu est ce que c'est pour donald trump
une façon de mettre la pression sur ses
différents partenaires que ce soit la
chine l'europe la russie et s'est lancé
dans cette aventure pour ce moment après
quatre ans il n'y a plus n'est pas
timide de mettre de pression sur les
gens sur les sujets qui lie quoique sont
très importants donc il est dir est
ils n'étaient pas il n'était pas très
populaire au début je ne sais pas si ça
a changé mais il avance il avancé avec
le projet il avance il a avancé avec
juste et des finances pour l'otan par
exemple qu'il y aura ce n'était pas
d'accord et c'était bon c'était pompeux
le monde et vous avez vu que tu les
choses qu'ils ont fait que le thé en
moyenne en riant donc oui il y aura des
mais c'est pas face à face et c'est vrai
tueur jeu j'ai compris donc ça c'est un
peu plus difficile d'avoir les bons
négociations avec les autres dirigeants
je sais quoi je crois que ios dont on
entend souvent donald trump dire michael
redd il faire des deals justement de
faire des accords par visioconférence ce
sera plus compliqué c'est ce que vous
dites
évidemment oui mais vivace et c'est sûr
il va parler directement
virtuellement aux autres dirigeants et
et on verra je ne sais pas tout les
choses qui vancouver dans son discours
mais le shérif opus on sait qu'il ya le
climat également qui sera qui sera
abordé cette semaine d'ailleurs antonio
guterres est cela dit on vient de
l'entente de secrétaire général des
nations unies donald trump a eu des
propos durs récemment avec les feux du
côté de l'ouest américain vis-à-vis des
élus démocrates des propos
climato-sceptiques est ce que il risque
d'y avoir des échanges musclés à ce
propos justement avec avec ses
partenaires à l'international lors de
cette semaine à l'onu à ce sujet au
sujet du climat aux muscles et il y
avait déjà tellement des discussions
musclées pendant les dîners à 4,4 à nec
je crois que tu le monde qu'on comprend
qu'on prenne nos positions des deux ans
déjà que il n'est pas d'accord c'est le
changement climatique riet des incendies
en californie
comme beaucoup beaucoup de gens il y
avait des avait dde et des gens qu'ils
ont à démarrer les feux éteints
finalement avec un feu d'artifice
il y avait des mâles gestion de forêts
si on peut dire en français normalement
il ya des incendies contrôlés pour
minimiser les grands gonfle donc un
petit peu quand même donald trump le
le climat qui est en train de changer
est-ce que ça minimiser quoi ses chances
dans l'action six à deux questions est
ce qui ne minimise pas ce que disent les
scientifiques
on est prêt c'est une consule j'ai donc
les gens il ya des gens qui croient que
tu les changements de 2,2 des problèmes
de climat tornades et les zorra gants
sont tous les problèmes de un changement
de climat et il ya d autres gens qui dit
que oui peut-être mais peut-être pas
donc on n'est pas sûr dans l'entreprise
des questions c'est pas que ils disent
que non je ne suis pas d'accord du tout
il dit que peut-être parce qu'il ya
beaucoup des scientistes qui sont pas
sûr non plus et ils disent les opinions
opposants peut-être mais il cherche des
solutions pratiques toujours si on dise
que c'est le changement climatique
rillettes ou les incendies en kadhafi ni
californie et de rejoindre l'accord
perry essayer de réduire les émissions
co2 pour éviter les incendies
peut-être mais ces longues thème
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pragmatiques
les gestion de forêts a arrêté des des
choses
un autre horizon pour les incendies
c'est l'électrique grid on dit en
anglais ou qui sait très très vieux et
ça les transformer explose parce qu'ils
sont très vieux parce que l'état de
californie mais pas les finances pour
améliorer l'électricité les lignes
d'électricité autour de ta tendance
voudrait améliorer les choses comme ça
peut éviter les incendies et les
problèmes tout de suite ça sens unique à
ce qui va se passer lors de cette
assemblée générale des nations unies au
cours de cette semaine et on attend donc
le
10 courant de donald trump qui devrait
arriver d'ici quelques minutes rester
avec nous à bologhine on débriefera
ensemble le discours de donald trump
d'ici quelques minutes
il devrait s'exprimer incessamment sous
peu